im baden-württembergischen schwäbisch
hall lässt die stadt im zentrum diese
straße aufwendig sanieren
optisch sehr gelungen aber die neuen
pflastersteine machen richtig ärger die
13 millionen euro sanierung hält den
belastungen des busverkehrs nicht stand
die steine brechen der unterbau ist
nicht tragfähig überall gibt es
gefährliche stolperfallen
das ist eine reine buckelpiste hier also
sie können ja kaum mit dem kinderwagen
normalgröße lauf ist meine meinung ist
einfach einsam als richtig oder gar
nicht
bei der sanierung der straße am spital
bach will die stadt keine 08 15 lösung
sondern innovativ seien wegen des
gefälles und der starken belastung durch
den verkehr für 2012 ein gitter aus
stahlschienen eingebaut so soll das
pflaster nicht verrutschen das ganze
geht gründlich daneben wie ein gutachten
an den tag bringt das die stadt in
auftrag gibt der experte stellt der
konstruktion ein verheerendes zeugnis
aus laut gutachten liegen zahlreiche
planungsfehler vor es wurden die
grundlagen der entwässerung nicht
beachtet und regelwerks vorgaben nicht
eingehalten
eigentlich müssten alle pflasterstein
raus und die ganze straße noch einmal
komplett neu gebaut werden
wie es aussieht ist es alle tiefgang im
rathaus von schwäbisch hall macht man
keinerlei anstalten das debakel
kleinzureden schriftlich heißt es es war
eine bewusste entscheidung der stadt den
spital bach nicht zuletzt aus
ästhetischen gründen in dieser form zu
gestalten und damit höhere
unterhaltungskosten hinzunehmen um das
problem in den griff zu bekommen hat
sich die stadt fürs prinzip
flickschusterei entschieden allein die
reparatur in diesem sommer hat 40.000
euro gekostet das wird wohl nicht die
letzte gewesen sein